This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. The Paris Olympics kicked off last week, and the opening ceremonies were something else. They were awesome. The metal band Gojira blasted pyrotechnics from a castle alongside a headless Marie Antoinette. Celine Dion sang at the base of the Eiffel Tower. A masked torchbearer ran on the rooftops like Tom Cruise in Mission Impossible. And yes, there was an animal cruelty-free symbolic dove release. A mysterious figure rode on a metal horse down the Seine.
这里是 99% Invisible，我是罗曼·马尔斯。巴黎奥运会上周开幕，开幕式别具一格，简直棒极了。摇滚乐队“哥斯拉”在一座城堡旁燃放烟花，城堡窗前还立着一个玛丽·安托瓦内特的无头雕塑。席琳·迪翁在埃菲尔铁塔下高歌。一个戴着面具的火炬手在屋顶上奔跑，宛如《碟中谍》里的汤姆·克鲁斯。没错，现场还放飞了一只保护动物权益、象征和平的鸽子。一个神秘人物骑着一匹金属机械马沿着塞纳河缓缓前行。
Unfurling massive dove wings. It was weird and wonderful. This week we're presenting a freshly remixed pair of older Olympic stories from 99PI. We'll hear more about some long-lost Olympic events that we think should definitely be brought back. But first, this 2017 episode about the iconic design of the 1968 Games in Mexico City. Enjoy. The United States leads the Olympics in medal awards and is just about supreme in the sprint races. On October 16, 1968, American sprinters Tommy Smith and John Carlos climbed onto the podium
展开巨大的鸽子翅膀。这一切既怪异又美妙。本周，我们将为大家呈献两期经过重新混音制作的 99PI 旧奥运故事。我们将听到更多关于一些被遗忘的奥运项目的故事，我们认为这些项目绝对应该恢复。但首先，是这期制作于 2017 年的节目，讲述 1968 年墨西哥城奥运会的标志性设计。请欣赏。美国在奥运会奖牌榜上领跑，在短跑项目上也几乎占据绝对统治地位。1968 年 10 月 16 日，美国短跑运动员托米·史密斯和约翰·卡洛斯登上领奖台
at the Mexico City Olympics to accept their medals. Yesterday, they came in first and third in the 200-meter dash. Smith had won gold. Carlos had won bronze. As the national anthem began to play, the men, both African-American, bowed their heads and raised their fists in the Black Power Salute. That's producer Claire Mullen. They kept their fists raised
在墨西哥城奥运会上领取他们的奖牌。就在前一天，他们在 200 米短跑比赛中分别获得第一名和第三名。史密斯赢得了金牌，卡洛斯赢得了铜牌。当国歌奏响时，这两位非裔美国运动员低下了头，举起了象征“黑人权力的敬礼”的拳头。这是制作人克莱尔·穆伦。他们一直高举着拳头
until the last notes of the anthem faded away. The gesture was a statement of Black pride and defiance. It's still considered one of the most overtly political statements made in the history of the modern Olympic Games. But that wasn't the only politically significant moment at the Olympics that year. A Mexican hurdler named Enriqueta Basilio became the first woman to ever light the Olympic cauldron. A Czech gymnast beat out Soviet gymnasts for the overall women's title, just two months after the Soviet invasion of Czechoslovakia. It was also the first time a Latin American city, or even a Spanish-speaking country,
直到国歌的最后一个音符消散。这一姿态是黑人骄傲与抗争的宣言。它至今仍被视为现代奥运会历史上最具公开政治色彩的声明之一。但这并不是那届奥运会上唯一的具有政治意义的时刻。一位名叫恩里奎塔·巴西利奥的墨西哥跨栏运动员成为了历史上第一位点燃奥运圣火的女性。就在苏联入侵捷克斯洛伐克两个月后，一名捷克体操运动员在女子全能比赛中击败了苏联体操运动员。这也是第一次由拉丁美洲城市
had hosted the Games. It was a big deal to have hundreds of thousands of international travelers come visit Mexico. The Mexican government saw the Olympics as an announcement to the world. Mexico City had arrived as a major international metropolis. So almost everything about the 1968 Olympics felt revolutionary. Including the design of it.
甚至是一个西班牙语国家来主办奥运会。成千上万的国际游客来到墨西哥，这是一件大事。墨西哥政府将奥运会视为向世界发布的一个信号：墨西哥城已经崛起为一个重要的国际大都市。因此，1968 年奥运会的几乎所有方面都给人一种革命性的感觉，包括它的设计。
The images and logos associated with the 1968 Olympics were ubiquitous at the time. They were plastered all over the city. This complete design campaign would become one of the most famous in Olympic history, and it would set a whole new standard for games to come. But these government-commissioned designs would also be co-opted by local activists
与 1968 年奥运会相关的图像和标志在当时随处可见。它们被贴满了城市的每一个角落。这一完整的视觉设计战役成为奥运历史上最著名的设计之一，并为未来的奥运会树立了全新的标准。但是，这些由政府委托设计的作品，后来也被当地的活动人士所借用
who wanted to reveal the darker political reality in Mexico that was hidden behind the beautiful, glossy imagery of the 1968 games. In the decades leading up to the 1968 Olympics, Mexico had gone through a period of major economic growth. It became known as the Mexican Miracle. The Mexican Miracle typically, you know, historians conventionally speak
他们想要揭露隐藏在 1968 年奥运会美丽、光鲜的外表之下的墨西哥黑暗政治现实。在 1968 年奥运会之前的几十年里，墨西哥经历了一个经济大增长的时期，被称为“墨西哥奇迹”。“墨西哥奇迹”通常，你知道的，历史学家习惯上称之为
about it as a period spanning from the mid-1940s to the late 1960s. The country had rapidly industrialized, rapidly urbanized, and its capital, Mexico City, had grown into this enormous, sprawling metropolis. The city grew faster than it ever had in Mexico's modern history.
从 20 世纪 40 年代中期持续到 60 年代末的一段时期。该国迅速实现了工业化和城市化，其首都墨西哥城成长为一个庞大、蔓延的大都市。这座城市的扩张速度超过了墨西哥现代史上的任何时期。
That's Luis Castañeda. He's the author of Spectacular Mexico, Design, Propaganda, and the 1968 Olympics. Because of its size and layout, Mexico City was a challenging place to host a major international event like the Olympics. Mexico City was sprawling and spreading, still at the height of its miracle. I mean, even until the Olympics are literally about to happen, there are all these doubts
那是路易斯·卡斯塔涅达。他是《壮丽的墨西哥：设计、宣传与 1968 年奥运会》一书的作者。由于其规模和布局，墨西哥城要承办像奥运会这样的大型国际活动是一处充满挑战的地方。墨西哥城不断扩张蔓延，当时正处于其“奇迹”的巅峰。我的意思是，甚至直到奥运会即将开幕的时候，人们依然对以下种种事情充满疑虑
about whether the Mexican government will be organized enough to undertake the whole spectacle of that magnitude. The Olympic organizers needed to show that their metropolis was safe, navigable, cohesive, and, you know, exciting. They wanted to create a visual identity for the Olympics to really sell Mexico City to all these visitors seeing it for the Olympics to really sell Mexico City to all these visitors seeing it for the first time. So they decided to hold an international competition to find a designer who would create a logo
怀疑墨西哥政府是否有足够的组织能力来承办如此规模的宏大盛事。奥运会组织者需要向外界证明，他们的都市是安全、通达、凝聚力强且令人兴奋的。他们希望为奥运会创造一种视觉形象，向所有首次因奥运会来到这里的访客推销墨西哥城。因此，他们决定举办一场国际设计竞赛，寻找一位能为奥运会创作标志
and graphic design campaign for the Olympics. They wanted something that looked cosmopolitan and contemporary and distinctly Mexican. And this is where an unlikely character comes in. I'm Lance Wyman. I'm a designer. I work here in New York. In 1966, Lance Wyman was a 29-year-old graphic designer. When he heard about the competition, he knew that he and his design partner, Peter Murdock, had to get on the short list of contenders. This list included design teams from all over the world who would come down to Mexico City for a two-week trial run. After their two
和平面设计方案的设计师。他们想要一种既具大都市风范、现代感，又极具墨西哥特色，并且独一无二的风格。这就是一个意想不到的人物登场的地方。我是兰斯·怀曼。我是一名设计师。我在纽约工作。1966 年，兰斯·怀曼是一名 29 岁的平面设计师。当他听到这个竞赛的消息时，他知道他和他的设计搭档彼得·默多克必须入围候选名单。这份名单包括来自世界各地的设计团队，他们将前往墨西哥城进行为期两周的试用期。在这两周
weeks, each team would present their design for consideration. And we got on the list to go down in November of 1966 and Peter and I had just started out we didn't have any money so we could only afford one-way tickets. They hopped on the plane with their one-way tickets and landed in Mexico City. By the way, neither of them had ever visited Mexico before. They didn't really know anything about the country. If they were going to design a logo to represent Mexico, Wyman and Murdoch would have to learn a lot and fast.
过后，每个团队都要提交他们的设计供评选。我们在 1966 年 11 月入围并前往墨西哥城，当时我和彼得刚开始创业，身上没什么钱，所以我们只能买得起单程机票。他们揣着单程机票跳上飞机，降落在墨西哥城。顺便说一句，他们两人以前从没去过墨西哥，对这个国家几乎一无所知。如果他们要设计一个代表墨西哥的标志，怀曼和默多克就必须快速且大量地学习相关知识。
They started where most tourists start, by visiting museums. They spent a lot of time at the Museum of Anthropology, where they studied artifacts from pre-Columbian Mexico, like the Aztec Sunstone and ancient Mayan murals. I actually was floored by some of the early cultures because they were doing things in a contemporary way with geometry and with graphics. The bold lines and bright colors and geometric shapes reminded Wyman of the kind of op art that was popular among contemporary artists back in New York. Op art, or optical art, uses contrast, geometry, and other tricks to give the viewer the impression of movement. And so, informed by both indigenous artifacts and modern op art, Wyman came up with a logo
他们从大多数游客开始的地方入手——参观博物馆。他们在人类学博物馆花了大量时间，研究前哥伦布时期墨西哥的文物，比如阿兹特克太阳石和古代玛雅壁画。其实我被早期的一些文化彻底震撼了，因为他们在几何图形和平面设计上的做法非常具有现代感。那些大胆的线条、明亮的色彩和几何形状让怀曼想到了当时在纽约当代艺术家中风靡的光效应艺术。光效应艺术（Op art）利用对比、几何和其他视觉把戏，给观者带来运动的错觉。因此，在吸收了本土文物和现代光效应艺术的双重启发后，怀曼设计出了一个标志
that riffed on the five rings of the Olympic symbol. I realized that the geometry of the five rings could be integrated with the year of the event, 68. He superimposed the digits six and eight over the classic Olympic rings. The circles on the rings radiated out from the circles in the digits and it created a hypnotic stripe effect. And from that I developed the typography to make the word Mexico. It's this very groovy looking typography made of three parallel stripes. Wyman created
它巧妙地借鉴了奥运五环的标志。我意识到五个环的几何形状可以与当年的年份“68”结合起来。他将数字“6”和“8”重叠在经典的奥运五环之上。环上的圆圈从数字中的圆圈向外辐射，创造出了一种催眠般的条纹效果。由此，我开发出由三条平行线条组成的“Mexico”字样排版。怀曼创造了
a logo that he considered both very modern and quintessentially Mexican. The end of the two weeks came and we started making prints of the Mexico 68 logotype and people from publications and people from the public relations, they wanted copies of it. And we were working like crazy making copies and doing all of that. And then Wyman realized that no one actually told him yet if he had the job. So he asked one of the organizers. I said, did we win? He goes, oh, I guess so.
一个他认为既非常现代又极具墨西哥风情的标志。两周的时间结束了，我们开始打印“Mexico 68”的字标，出版界的人和公共关系部门的人都想要它的复印件。我们当时疯狂地工作，忙着复印和处理各种事情。然后怀曼才意识到，其实根本没人告诉他到底有没有被录用。于是他问了其中一位组织者。我说，我们赢了吗？他说，哦，大概吧。
Wyman had created a stunning logo and typeface for the competition. But choosing this white guy who had never been to Mexico before was a bit problematic. It's not that unusual for people not born in Mexico, for artists and people in culture and the arts to be involved with these kinds of state-sponsored campaigns. It's not entirely unprecedented, but it's still a very unique situation, especially given the fact that this is a very, very significant project. That's author Luis Castañeda again. What is very striking, almost shocking perhaps, is that the fact that of course Lance Wyman
怀曼为这次竞赛创作了一个惊艳的标志和字体。但选择这样一个从未去过墨西哥的白人确实有点问题。非墨西哥本土出生的人、艺术家以及文化艺术界人士参与这种国家资助的宣传活动，其实并不罕见。这并非完全没有先例，但仍然是一个非常独特的情况，特别是考虑到这是一个非常非常重大的项目。再次引用作家路易斯·卡斯塔涅达的话。最引人注目、甚至可以说是令人震惊的事实是，兰斯·怀曼
is very much unproven as a designer. He's very young, he hasn't had much time to do much yet. And yet somehow he is given this very high degree of responsibility as part of the design campaign. Wyman and Murdoch ended up staying in Mexico for two years to work on the campaign. And, along with a team of designers, many of them Mexican, they came up with ways to use their typeface, logo, and other designs all over the city. The hypnotic stripes were turned into striped uniforms for the event's workers and volunteers.
作为一名设计师，他基本上还名不见经传。他很年轻，没有太多时间去积累经验。然而，在设计战役中，他却被赋予了如此高度的责任。怀曼和默多克最终在墨西哥呆了两年，参与这项设计工作。他们和许多墨西哥设计师组成的设计团队一起，想方设法将他们的字体、标志和其他设计应用到城市的各个角落。那些催眠般的条纹被做成了赛事工作人员和志愿者的条纹制服。
The patterns and colors used in the logo ended up on hats, postage stamps, balloons, all sorts of products to hype the impending games. And these objects range from very small objects, all kinds of memorabilia, you know, things from ashtrays and furniture or apparel, all the way to the stadiums. Stadiums across the city were painted with these radiating op art patterns. Bright colors decorated sidewalks and walls and plazas. And these bright hypnotic designs didn't just give the Olympic games a visual coherence. The graphic design language of the Olympics expanded into an entire system that helped visitors navigate the massive metropolis. To do this, Wyman made simple color-coded icons to represent every sporting event.
标志中使用的图案和颜色最终出现在了帽子、邮票、气球以及各种为宣传即将到来的奥运会而制作的产品上。这些物品小到各种纪念品、烟灰缸、家具或服装，大到体育场馆。全城的体育场馆都涂上了这些辐射状的光效应艺术图案。明亮的色彩装点了人行道、墙壁和广场。这些明亮且带有催眠效果的设计不仅赋予了奥运会视觉上的连贯性。奥运会的平面设计语言还扩展成了一个完整的系统，帮助访客在巨大的都市中辨别方向。为此，怀曼制作了简单的色彩编码图标来代表每一个体育项目。
They were not stick figures, but they were focused more on a part of the body or a piece of the equipment or a combination of the two. Gymnastics, for example, was represented by a hand gripping a single suspended ring. Track and field had its icon, boxing had its icon. So on the ticket, you knew what your ticket was for by the icon only. So if you're visiting from Japan and didn't speak any Spanish you'd see say the soccer icon on a green background and you'd follow the green signs to the stadium where the soccer would be. And this system wasn't just for sports. Wyman and the team made universally understandable icons for
它们不是简笔画，而是更聚焦于身体的某一部分、一件器材，或者是两者的结合。例如，体操是用一只抓着单杠的手来代表的。田径有它的图标，拳击也有它的图标。所以在门票上，仅凭图标你就能知道你的票是看什么比赛的。因此，如果你是从日本来访、不会说西班牙语，你会看到绿底背景上的足球图标，然后沿着绿色标志走到举行足球比赛的体育场。这个系统不仅适用于体育赛事。怀曼和团队还为
19 cultural events happening around the city as well. We had children's painting, we had folk dancing, we had science programming. By following these cultural icons, visitors could continue to entertain themselves and explore the city after the sporting events were over. The 1968 Olympics had been decreed Los Juegos de la Paz, the Games of Peace. So Wyman designed a little outline of a dove which shop owners all over the city were given to stick in their windows. Between the logo, the typeface, the colors, the icons, and the doves, Wyman created a visual identity that saturated the whole city. It was everywhere.
全城进行的 19 场文化活动制作了普遍易懂的图标。我们有儿童绘画，有民间舞蹈，有科学节目。顺着这些文化图标，游客在体育赛事结束后可以继续娱乐并探索这座城市。1968 年奥运会被正式命名为“和平运动会”（Los Juegos de la Paz）。因此，怀曼设计了一个鸽子的轮廓，全城的店主都将其贴在窗户上。通过标志、字体、颜色、图标和鸽子，怀曼创造了一种充斥整座城市的视觉形象。它无处不在。
It was a total design campaign. Total design campaign, right? There's the idea of total design, that every single thing, idea, place, object associated with the Olympics is immediately and powerfully recognizable as part of a whole. And the completeness of the campaign would set a precedent for years to come. I think it's safe to say that although design and architecture and the arts in general had been very powerfully associated with Olympics before Mexico 68, it's really after Mexico 60 that it becomes a kind of standard expectation of design campaigns associated with these kinds of events. While Lance Wyman was designing this extensive campaign, he was holed up, swamped with work, and he really didn't get a chance to go out much. Nose to the grindstone, really,
这是一场全面的设计运动。全面的设计运动，对吧？“全面设计”的概念是，与奥运会相关的每一件物品、每一个想法、每一个地方和每一个对象，都能立即且有力地被识别为一个整体的一部分。这场运动的完整性为未来的岁月树立了先例。我认为可以肯定的是，尽管在 1968 年墨西哥奥运会之前，设计、建筑和一般艺术就已经与奥运会有着非常强烈的联系，但真正让它成为人们对同类活动设计战役的标准期待的，正是在 1968 年墨西哥奥运会之后。当兰斯·怀曼正在设计这庞大的活动时，他正埋头苦干、工作缠身，几乎没有机会出去走走。埋头苦干，真的，
almost through the whole thing. We were pretty isolated at the Olympic Committee. He didn't see the protest movement growing in the city around him. The movement was led by students who believed the long-ruling institutional revolutionary party catered to wealthy Mexicans rather than the poor, rural, and working class. The country had been experiencing huge economic growth, but millions of people had been left behind. The Mexican miracle hadn't reached everyone. The government was talking of the Mexican miracle, even though in the reality of those days,
几乎贯穿了整个过程。我们在奥组委里相当孤立。他没有看到自己身边的城市里正在滋长的抗议运动。这场运动由学生领导，他们认为长期执政的体制革命党迎合了富裕的墨西哥人，而不是穷人、农村居民和工人阶级。国家经历了巨大的经济增长，但数百万人民却被抛在了后面。墨西哥奇迹并没有惠及所有人。政府在大谈“墨西哥奇迹”，尽管在那些日子的现实中，
things were not as happy as they appeared. These are excerpts from interviews with students involved in the protests against Mexico's single-party government, courtesy of our friends at Radio Diaries. In the 60s, we were still a country where the government controlled everything. Presidents were the equivalent of monarchs. I mean, it was forbidden to demonstrate. You could not go and express your dissent. And for the students, protesting the government meant protesting against the Olympics themselves. to demonstrate. You could not go and express your dissent. And for the students, protesting the government meant protesting against the Olympics themselves, the so-called Games of Peace.
事情并不像表面看起来那么愉快。这些是从参与反对墨西哥一党制政府抗议活动的学生采访中摘录的片段，由我们的朋友 Radio Diaries 提供。在 60 年代，我们仍然是一个政府控制一切的国家。总统就相当于君主。我的意思是，游行示威是违法的。你不能去表达你的异议。对学生来说，抗议政府就意味着抗议奥运会本身。示威是违法的。你不能去表达你的异议。对学生来说，抗议政府就意味着抗议奥运会本身，即所谓的“和平运动会”。
Olympics are, I think maybe by design, by definition, always about propaganda on some level or another. And so what the Olympics sought to present as a kind of happy picture of social harmony and as a kind of very sanitized idea of how modernization happens was of course not the reality of what many of these inhabitants of the city experienced. Tens of thousands of protesters took to the streets repeatedly throughout 1968. We were urban middle class, low middle class, bunch of young people. It was in a symbolic way the clash of a new Mexico and a new Mexico. You have a middle class with eyes closed and a group of students saying this was not a democracy and this is not working. Again and again police had come out and violently dispersed protesters with clouds of tear gas.
奥运会，我想也许在设计和定义上，在某种程度上总是关乎政治宣传。因此，奥运会试图呈现的社会和谐的快乐图景，以及对现代化发生过程的一种高度美化的想象，当然不是这座城市的许多居民所经历的现实。整个 1968 年，成千上万的抗议者屡屡走上街头。我们是城市中产阶级、下中产阶级，一群年轻人。从象征意义上讲，这是新墨西哥与旧墨西哥的冲突。一方面是闭目塞听的中产阶级，另一方面是一群学生，他们说这不是民主，这行不通。警察一次又一次地出动，用催泪瓦斯驱散抗议者。
As the Olympics neared and as international attention turned towards Mexico City, the government was desperate to make the unrest go away. On October 2nd, just 10 days before the Games of Peace were set to begin, thousands of students gathered at Tlatelolco Square in the northeast of Mexico City to demand the Games of Peace were set to begin, thousands of students gathered at Tlatelolco Square in the northeast of Mexico City to demand the release of people who had been locked up at a previous protest. It was a quiet gathering of people with signs, walking slowly around the plaza. And we looked back and there was all these infantry troops. They started to advance towards the crowd.
随着奥运会临近，国际注意力转向墨西哥城，政府迫切希望平息动荡。10 月 2 日，也就是“和平运动会”开幕前仅仅 10 天，数千名学生聚集在墨西哥城东北部的特拉特洛尔科广场，要求释放那些在之前的抗议活动中被关押的人。这是一个安静的集会，人们举着标语，在广场上缓缓走动。当我们回头看时，发现全都是步兵部队。他们开始向人群推进。
And at some point we heard some shots. We didn't know where they came from. And seconds later, how do you say in English, all hell broke loose. Soldiers opened fire on the protesters. To this day, we don't know exactly how many students died in the massacre, but the number is likely in the hundreds. The scene was cleared before there could be an accurate body count. The blood was washed away.
在某个时刻，我们听到了一些枪声。我们不知道它们是从哪里来的。几秒钟后，英语里怎么说来着，一切都乱成了一团。士兵向抗议者开枪。直到今天，我们仍然不知道在大屠杀中有多少学生丧生，但这个数字很可能是几百人。在能够准确清点人数之前，现场就被清理干净了。血迹被冲洗掉。
Thousands of protesters were arrested and locked up. The government took great pains to cover their tracks. The amount of students who were shot and many others who were imprisoned for quite some time was covered up. The government claimed that the students had fired first to provoke the military. Evidence has since come to light that disproves that claim. It's an extremely shocking event for a long time, kind of suppressed in Mexican national memory.
成千上万的抗议者被捕并关押。政府煞费苦心地掩盖他们的行踪。被枪杀的学生人数以及许多被长期监禁的人数都被掩盖了。政府声称是学生先开枪挑衅军队的。此后出现的证据驳斥了这一说法。这是一场极具震撼力的事件，长期以来在墨西哥的国家记忆中被某种程度地压制了。
And in many ways, it is the crux of the crisis that sets the stage for the, in a very, very dramatic sense for the Olympics themselves. The massacre was so horribly devastating that, of course, Lance Wyman heard about it. When I heard about it, and how severe it was, it was a difficult situation because I felt I was working for the government and I couldn't do anything about it. But he says he really empathized with the students. I couldn't do anything about it. But he says he really empathized with the students. I wasn't much older than they were,
在许多方面，它是危机的核心，为奥运会的召开铺垫了非常非常戏剧化的背景。这场大屠杀是如此惨烈，以至于兰斯·怀曼当然也听说了。当我听说这件事及其严重程度时，这是一种艰难的状况，因为我觉得我在为政府工作，却对此无能为力。但他说他 realmente 对学生们感同身受。我对此无能为力。但他说他对学生们感同身受。我比他们大不了多少，
so I had that feeling that I might have felt good if I just walked away from the whole thing. Wyman felt stuck in the middle. But in a way, he didn't need to choose between the government and the protesters. His designs found a way to serve both sides. Students began imitating Wyman's images and co-opting them. They took a poster he made with a silhouetted image of runners racing and turned it into
所以我有一种感觉，如果我直接一走了之，也许心里会好受些。怀曼感到夹在中间进退两难。但在某种程度上，他不需要在政府和抗议者之间做出选择。他的设计找到了服务双方的途径。学生们开始模仿怀曼的图像并对其进行挪用。他们把他制作的一张以赛跑运动员剪影为主题的海报，改造成了
silhouettes of troops beating people with batons. They used his signature typography to create anti-government posters. And that very simple image of a dove in all the shop windows? Students went around the city, spraying a small burst of bright red in all the shop windows, students went around the city spraying a small burst of bright red paint over the dove's chest, like it had been shot. They were playing with the propaganda of the Olympics and hinting at a darker political reality. And Wyman, he liked it. He made a design campaign so ubiquitous, so resonant, that the resistance could use it too.
士兵用警棍殴打行人的剪影。他们使用他标志性的字体来制作反政府海报。还有所有店铺橱窗里那张简单的鸽子海报？学生们走遍全城，在所有店铺橱窗的鸽子胸口喷上一小团鲜红的油漆，就像它被枪击了一样。他们借用奥运会的宣传来暗示更黑暗的政治现实。而怀曼，他很喜欢这样。他设计了一个无处不在、充满共鸣的设计战役，以至于抵抗运动也能利用它。
And I've always been questioned, well, why do you feel good about that? And I guess that's why, because I was in a situation where I was kind of torn. I was very sympathetic as far as what was happening to the students, but I was also very not wanting to see the Olympics be stopped. And they weren't stopped. On October 12, 1968, the Games began on schedule. As if nothing out of the ordinary had happened. On October 12, 1968, the Olympic Games of Mexico were inaugurated.
我一直被问到，好吧，你为什么对此感觉良好？我想这就是原因，因为我当时处于一种左右为难的境地。我对学生们的遭遇非常同情，但我也非常不希望看到奥运会被取消。而它们并没有被取消。1968 年 10 月 12 日，奥运会按计划开幕。就像什么都没发生过一样。1968 年 10 月 12 日，墨西哥奥运会开幕了。
The 1968 Olympics went on to become one of the most important in the history of the games, marked not only by athletic achievement, but by open political defiance. I represented black America. I'm very proud to be a black man and also to have won the gold medal Mexico 68 also set a new precedent for how governments would use design to promote their country's image to the international community For better or for worse the 68 games also left a permanent mark on Mexico City's infrastructure The 68 games also left a permanent mark on Mexico City's infrastructure. Mexico City is one of the largest cities in the world. It's the largest metropolitan area in North America. Around 4.4 million people ride on Mexico City's metro system every day, including producer Claire Mullen, who visited a couple months ago. I'm in the metro on the pink line at Cuauhtemoc,
1968 年奥运会成为奥运史上最重要的几届运动会之一，它不仅以体育成就为标志，更以公开的政治抗议而著称。我代表了黑人美国。我为自己是一个黑人感到非常自豪，也为在 68 年墨西哥奥运会上赢得金牌而骄傲。68 年奥运会还为各国政府如何利用设计向国际社会宣传国家形象树立了新标准。不管好坏，68 年奥运会也在墨西哥城的基础设施上留下了永久的印记。68 年奥运会也在墨西哥城的基础设施上留下了永久的印记。墨西哥城是世界上最大的城市之一。它是北美最大的都会区。大约有 440 万人每天乘坐墨西哥城的地铁系统，其中包括制作人克莱尔·穆伦，她几个月前去参观过。我在地铁粉红线上，在夸乌特莫克站，
which has an eagle icon. Mexico City's metro is incredibly crowded and very extensive. And yet, it is often recognized as one of the easiest rail systems to navigate, partly because of its iconography. La Católica, which is a big ship. It looks like a pirate ship without the pirate symbol. And then we have Merced, where there are six apples in a crate.
这里有一个老鹰的图标。墨西哥城的地铁拥挤异常，且四通八达。然而，它常常被认为是最容易辨认方向的铁路系统之一，部分原因就在于其图标系统。拉卡托利卡站，那是一艘大船。它看起来像一艘没有海盗标志的海盗船。然后我们来到梅瑟德站，那里有一个板条箱装着六个苹果。
And those icons are there, thanks in part to Lance Wyman. The Metro was supposed to make its debut during the Olympics, but excavators kept unearthing ancient architecture in the path of the tracks, and the opening was delayed. But Wyman was still involved in its design, specifically its map. He employed the same visual system he developed for the Olympics to help international visitors navigate the trains. In the Olympics, we relied on the graphics, and I thought, well, why can't a city do that?
这些图标的存在，部分要归功于兰斯·怀曼。地铁本应在奥运会期间首次亮相，但挖掘机在轨道沿线不断发掘出古代建筑，导致开幕推迟。但怀曼仍然参与了它的设计，特别是它的地图。他采用了他为奥运会开发的视觉系统，来帮助国际游客在列车网络中导航。在奥运会期间，我们依赖图形，我想，为什么一个城市不能这样做呢？
So Wyman color-coded each line and created a unique icon for every single stop. So, even if you're visiting from Japan and can't read any Spanish at all, you can say to yourself, I want to take the pink line to the stop with the grasshopper on it. The station that stopped at Chapultepec Park, Chapultepec means grasshopper hill in the Nahuatl, the Aztec language, so I used a grasshopper. Again, some Mexicans took issue with this young foreigner coming in to design something that would be such a huge part of their city.
于是，怀曼用颜色区分了每条线路，并为每一站创造了一个独一无二的图标。所以，即使你是从日本来访、完全不懂西班牙语，你也可以对自己说，我想坐粉红线去那个有蚂蚱标志的站。停在查普尔特佩克公园的那个车站，“查普尔特佩克”在阿兹特克语纳瓦特尔语中是“蚂蚱山”的意思，所以我用了一只蚂蚱。同样，一些墨西哥人对这个年轻的外国人进来设计一个将成为他们城市巨大组成部分的东西提出了异议。
But eventually, Mexican designers took up the project and made it their own. You know, I designed the first three lines of the Metro and all the they have 12 lines now and they were designed by Mexican designers and some of these are better than I did in the original line. After the Olympics, after the metro, Wyman did some more work for Mexico like the design for the 1970 World Cup but he went back to the US. Wyman went on to design more maps, big ones, like for the National Zoo and the D.C. Metro system, although none of them used symbols and icons and colors as completely as in Mexico City.
但最终，墨西哥设计师们接手了这个项目，并将其打造成了他们自己的东西。你知道的，我设计了地铁的前三条线以及所有……他们现在有 12 条线了，都是由墨西哥设计师设计的，其中有些甚至比我最初设计的线路还要好。奥运会和地铁之后，怀曼为墨西哥做了一些其他设计，比如 1970 年世界杯的设计，但他还是回到了美国。怀曼继续设计了更多的地图，大型的地图，比如为国家动物园和华盛顿特区地铁系统设计的地图，尽管其中没有一个像墨西哥城那样全面地使用符号、图标和颜色。
The clear iconography of the Metro system is a reminder of a complicated and sometimes terrible period in Mexico City's history. It's a simple design that invites you to explore the massive and complex metropolis. It's a design that assures you that if you get lost, no matter where you're from or what language you speak, you can find your way around and see the city for yourself. After the break, an Olympic road not taken.
地铁系统清晰的图标是对墨西哥城历史上一段复杂有时甚至可怕时期的提醒。这是一个简单的设计，邀请你去探索这个庞大而复杂的都市。这是一个向你保证的设计：无论你来自哪里，说什么语言，如果你迷路了，你都能找到方向，亲眼看看这座城市。休息过后，一段未曾选择的奥运之路。
The Olympic Games seem almost timeless going back to ancient Greece, so it can be easy to forget that the modern games as we know them today were only launched just over a century ago. Last week we heard about firefighting and tug of war, which tug of war has to come back in the Olympics. I mean, I think this might be my new mission in life. But what about Olympic poetry? Kurt Kohlstedt told us about it back in 2021.
奥运会似乎跨越时空、源远流长，可以追溯到古希腊，因此人们很容易忘记，我们今天所知的现代奥运会仅仅在一个多世纪前才刚刚起步。上周我们听说了消防和拔河比赛，拔河比赛真该回归奥运会。我的意思是，我觉得这可能是我的新生活使命。但是奥运会诗歌呢？库尔特·科尔斯特德在 2021 年就向我们讲述过。
To get things started, Roman, I'm gonna have you read the first stanza of a poem. It's titled, Ode to Sport, and it was written in 1912, 16 years after the first modern Olympic Games. Okay, here we go. O Sport, pleasure of the gods, essence of life, you appeared suddenly in the midst of the gray clearing which writhes with the drudgery of modern existence, like the radiant messenger of a past age, when mankind still smiled, and the glimmer of dawn lit up the mountaintops
为了开个头，罗曼，我请你朗读一首诗的第一节。它题为《体育颂》，写于 1912 年，即第一届现代奥运会举办 16 年后。好的，我们开始。啊，体育，天神的快乐，生命的本质，你突然出现在那片被现代生存的苦役所折磨、扭曲的灰色林间空地中，犹如来自一个古老时代的放射着光芒的信使，那时人类还在微笑，晨曦的微光照亮了山巅，
and flecks of light dotted the ground in the gloomy forests. Well done. That was excellent. So, other than them having a really dim view of the modern condition, what is that poem about? Well, see, it's not just any poem. It's an Olympic poem. And I don't mean that it's a poem about the Olympics. I mean it literally won an Olympic gold medal for literature.
点点光斑洒在阴暗森林的地面上。干得好。太棒了。那么，除了他们对现代社会状况持有相当黯淡的看法之外，这首诗到底是关于什么的？嗯，你看，它可不只是一首普通的诗。它是一首奥运诗歌。我的意思并不是说这是一首关于奥运会的诗。我是说它实实在在地赢得了奥运会文学金牌。
Okay. Okay. I mean, I don't know about every sport in the Olympics, but I'm pretty sure literature is not one that I'm familiar with at all. Yeah, you're right. And nobody is today, for the most part. But for decades, the Olympic Games actually did include competitions that fell under these five main artistic categories and one of those was literature. And so because I only think of them as sporting events and decathlons and pentathlons, how did literature find its way into the Olympics?
好吧。好吧，我的意思是，我对奥运会上的每个项目可能不太了解，但我敢肯定文学绝对不是我所熟悉的项目之一。是的，你说得对。大部分人现在也都这么觉得。但在过去的几十年里，奥运会确实包括了归属于这五个主要艺术类别的比赛，其中之一就是文学。既然我只把它们当作体育赛事、十项全能和五项全能，文学是怎么进入奥运会的呢？
Well, it started with this person who was broadly credited with launching the modern Olympics, Pierre de Coubertin. And he was this French aristocrat who advocated for and then ultimately organized the International Olympic Committee, which is still around today. So he's at the forefront of Olympics in general, and that committee decided to host the very first modern International Olympics in 1896. And they chose Athens as the host city, which was, of course, a nod to the ancient Greek Olympics.
这一切始于被广泛认为发起现代奥运会的人——皮埃尔·德·顾拜旦。他是一位法国贵族，倡导并最终组建了至今依然存在的国际奥林匹克委员会。因此，他站在奥运会整体发展的最前沿，该委员会决定在 1896 年举办第一届现代国际奥运会。他们选择雅典作为主办城市，这当然也是对古希腊奥运会的一种致敬。
So the first modern games in Athens, they did both feature sports and arts like that? Well, not quite yet. The very first set of games was basically what you'd expect. It had sports like swimming and weightlifting and fencing. But then after we'd had a couple of good successful games, also turned around sports, Coubertin sprung this idea on the IOC in 1906.
那么在雅典举办的第一届现代奥运会，既有体育项目，也有这样的艺术项目吗？嗯，还没完全开始。第一届奥运会基本上就是你所期待的那样。它有游泳、举重和击剑等体育项目。但在我们举办了几届顺利成功的、也围绕体育展开的奥运会之后，顾拜旦在 1906 年向国际奥委会提出了这个想法。
He basically was like, here we go. Like, why don't we also add these arts categories I've been thinking about? And those were architecture, literature, music, painting and sculpture. Architecture, now we're cooking our gas here. — Right? — Okay, keep going.
他基本上就是说：我们开始吧。为什么不也加上我一直在考虑的这些艺术类别呢？这些类别包括建筑、文学、音乐、绘画和雕塑。建筑，我们这下可说到点子上了。——对吧？——好，继续。
— And so these architects and other artists participating in this new, quote, pantathlon of the muses, unquote, were supposed to be amateurs, much like their counterparts competing on the sports side. — It all seems like a pretty big departure from, you know, what I think of as the ancient Olympics. Were those always centered around sports too? I mean, they were for the most part, but there were some ancient Olympic competitions for music or singing or even what's called heralding, which I gather just involved announcing things
——因此，参加这个被称为“缪斯五项全能”新项目（带引号）的建筑师和其他艺术家，应该都是业余爱好者，就像他们在体育领域的同行一样。——这一切听起来与我所认为的古希腊奥运会有相当大的出路。古希腊奥运会过去也完全是以体育为中心的吗？我的意思是，它们大部分是的，但也有一些古希腊奥运会比赛项目是关于音乐、歌唱、甚至是所谓的“宣报”，我猜这大概只是大声
really loudly. I don't know. And so, Cooper Tend kind of referred to that in his arguments for including the arts in the modern Olympics. And he wrote, quote, in the high times of Olympia, the fine arts were combined harmoniously with the Olympic Games to create their glory. This is to become reality once again, End quote. But, and I find this part strange for some reason. All of these artistic entries were also supposed to be related to sports. Which, I mean, the poem you had me read at the top was like that. It was about sports.
宣布事情而已。我不知道。因此，顾拜旦在为现代奥运会引入艺术进行辩护时提到了这一点。他写道：“在奥林匹亚的盛世，美术与奥运会和谐地结合在一起，创造了它们的辉煌。这一切将再次成为现实。”但是，不知为何我发现这一部分很奇怪。所有这些艺术参赛作品也都应该与体育有关。也就是说，你让我开头朗读的那首诗就是这样的。它是关于体育的。
I mean, I don't know if like, if you were judging all poems equally, if one about sports would necessarily win the gold medal, but when it comes to poems in the Olympics during this era, they had to be about sports, correct? Yeah, exactly. So it was kind of limiting. And so in the realm of architecture, for example, contenders submitted stuff like athletic stadiums and sporting complexes and playing fields and swimming pools and even ski jumps. And some of those pieces were published during the Olympics, like that's where they kind of first appeared, but others were actually built structures, like out in the world.
我的意思是，我不知道，如果你对所有诗歌进行同等评判，关于体育的诗是否一定会赢得金牌，但说到这个时期的奥运会诗歌，它们必须是关于体育的，对吗？是的，完全正确。所以这在某种程度上是有限制的。因此，在建筑领域，例如，参赛者提交的东西包括运动场、体育综合体、运动场、游泳池甚至滑雪跳台。其中一些作品是在奥运会期间出版的——就像它们首次亮相的那样——但另一些则是真正建造出来的实体结构，就建在现实世界中。
So they were judging actual built structures. It's not just, like, how did you bring your building to Athens? Like, how did that work? Right, so in most cases, whether or not the thing was built, they relied on renderings. But there were exceptions. So in the 1928 games in Amsterdam,
所以他们在评判实际建造的结构。不仅仅是，比如，你怎么把你的建筑带到雅典？这是怎么运作的？对的，所以在大多数情况下，无论该建筑是否真的被建造出来，他们都依靠效果图。但也有例外。因此在 1928 年的阿姆斯特丹奥运会上，
there was this Dutch architect who won the gold medal for the stadium that was being used in those Olympics. Talk about a home field advantage. Right, I mean, it does seem like it being there maybe could skew the judges a little bit. But the crazy thing is like by this time, there were a lot of submissions. Like that year alone, there were over a thousand works
有位荷兰建筑师凭借那届奥运会正在使用的体育场赢得了金牌。真可以说是占尽了主场之利。没错，我的意思是，这确实让人感觉身处主场可能会对评委产生一点影响。但疯狂的是，到这个时候，已经有很多参赛作品了。仅那一年，就有上千件
of art submitted in all these different categories. Wow. It's kind of amazing to me that there was this period of time where there were that many submissions and it was that big a part of the games, but no one knows about this period of time in the Olympics history. Right? And for, like, I didn't either. I mean, you know, I went to architecture school.
艺术作品在所有这些不同的类别中被提交。哇。这对我来说有点神奇，竟然曾有过这样一个时期，有这么多的参赛作品，而且它们是奥运会如此重要的一部分，但居然没有人知道奥运会历史上的这一时期。对吧？而且，就像，我也不知道。我的意思是，你知道的，我上过建筑学校。
You'd think that they would teach you about the architectural Olympics. But no, they kind of faded from memory. But for a long time, they were really a big deal. And the IOC even got to the point of adding new subcategories within the arts, like orchestra and dramatic works, even town planning. And so these creative competitions grew popular. And one side effect was that they started to naturally draw in people who were more like aspiring professionals and even veteran creatives.
你本以为他们会教你关于建筑奥运会的内容。但并没有，它们有点淡出了人们的记忆。但在很长一段时间里，它们确实是一件大事。国际奥委会甚至在艺术领域增加了新的子类别，比如管弦乐、戏剧作品，甚至城市规划。因此，这些创意比赛越来越受欢迎。一个副作用是，它们开始自然而然地吸引那些更像是有志成为专业人士甚至资深创意人士的人。
And some of these participating artists were even selling their artworks during the games. Well, that seems to be somewhat in the violation of the spirit of the games, you know, just to use it as a showcase for selling your work. It's like a big gallery show. Right. If the act of being in the games turns you from an amateur to a professional, then that makes things kind of complicated. It does. And really this idea of amateurism was something that the IOC was pushing more
其中一些参赛艺术家甚至在比赛期间出售他们的艺术品。嗯，这似乎有点违背奥运会精神，你知道的，只是把它当作一个展示和出售你作品的平台。就像一个大型画廊展览一样。没错。如果参加比赛的行为把你从一个业余爱好者变成了一个专业人士，那事情就变得有点复杂了。确实如此。老实说，这种对业余精神的强调正是国际奥委会在随着时间推移、步入 20 世纪 40 年代时越来越力推的东西。因此，艺术自然成了靶子，对吧？就像它是那个不像大家想象的那样纯属业余的显眼目标。坦白说，你知道的，这种对业余的专注一开始对艺术来说就有点勉强。那位因建造奥运体育场而获奖的建筑师，很显然他不是业余爱好者。
and more as time went on and we were getting into the 1940s. So the arts became this natural target, right? Like it was the obvious thing that was like not being quite as amateur as everybody thought it would be. And frankly, you know, this amateur focus to begin with was a bit of a stretch for the arts. And that architect who won the award for building that Olympic stadium, like obviously he wasn't an amateur.
没错。是的，你总不能用业余体育场来举办奥运会，你知道的，比如对建筑规范只是业余遵守的那种。没错，没错。就像对一个想法的粗略草图一样，你知道的，差不多就行了。还有其他问题。比如有些艺术家不想参加，因为他们可能会输，这会损害他们的声誉。
Right. Yeah, you couldn't host the Olympic games in an amateur stadium, you know, like with amateur adherence to building guidelines, for example. Right, right. Just like a rough sketch of an idea, you know, it'll be fine. And there were other problems too. Like some artists didn't want to participate because they might lose and that could damage their reputation.
然后，你知道的，正如你之前提到的，这种对体育的专注是相当有限的。因此，在 1948 年伦敦奥运会之后，国际奥委会干脆完全取消了艺术比赛。现在有一个叫作“文化奥林匹克”的东西，它是独立的，但实际上主要赛事和奖牌还是颁给体育项目的。我的意思是，这让我震惊的是它竟然一直持续到了 1948 年。这就意味着有大约 30 年或更长的时间里，存在着
And then, you know, as you mentioned before, it's like this sports focus was pretty limiting. And so eventually after the London games in 48, the IOC just discontinued the arts competitions altogether. And now there's this thing called the Cultural Olympiad, which is separate, but really like the main events and the medals are for sports. I mean, that's stunning to me that it lasted until 1948. So that means that there's like a stretch of like 30 years or more where there were
这些艺术奖牌得主。在这个群体里有我认识的人吗？你知道的，他们大多不是什么名人，不管是好是坏。我个人觉得最有趣的，是他们推动奥运会理念的方式，或者是那些创造了不寻常纪录的事情。例如，在 1912 年有一位奥运选手，他既赢得了游泳奖牌，又赢得了雕塑奖牌。对我和来说，这真的很酷。就像是，哇，这真的是竞争中的自由艺术，对吧？你既能赢得艺术奖项，又能赢得体育奖牌。
these artistic medal winners. Like are there anybody that I would know of in that cohort? You know, most of them aren't famous people, for better or for worse. Like the ones I actually find most interesting are these like, like ways in which they kind of like pushed the idea of the Olympics or like things that like set unusual records. So for example, there was this Olympian in 1912, who won a medal for swimming while he also won a medal for sculpture. Like to me, that's really cool. Like that's like, wow, that's really the liberal arts of competition, right? You can like win art and sports.
还有一个艺术类的优胜者，获奖时已经 73 岁高龄了。我们通常认为奥运选手都很年轻，但在艺术领域，真的任何年龄都可以申请。然后还有顾拜旦本人，他在 1912 年巴黎奥运会上赢得了艺术类别的金牌。等一下。我的意思是，他帮助启动了奥运会，可以说是现代奥运会的奠基人，然后他自己还参加了奥运会？是的！是的，他参加了。而且他凭借
And then there was this winner in the arts who was 73 years old when he won. You know, we think of Olympic contenders being pretty young, but it's like in the arts really any age can apply. And then there's Coubertin himself, who won a gold medal in an arts category in the 1912 Paris Olympics. Pete Slauson Wait a second. I mean, he helped jumpstart the Olympics, like sort of the founder of the modern Olympics, and then he competed in the Olympics. Jared Slauson Yes! Yes, he did. And he won his award for
然后还有一位艺术奖的得主，他获奖时已经73岁了。你知道的，我们通常认为奥运选手都很年轻，但在艺术领域，实际上任何年龄都可以参加。然后是顾拜旦本人，他在1912年巴黎奥运会上获得了艺术类别的金牌。皮特·斯劳森：等一下。我的意思是，他帮助重启了奥运会，可以说是现代奥运会的创始人，然后他自己还参加了奥运会。贾里德·斯劳森：是的！是的，他参加了。而且他获奖是因为
literature. Or more specifically, poetry. Pete Slauson Did he write that poem at the top that you made me read? That's the one. Coubertin submitted it under a pseudonym, and he won the gold! Well, I'm sure there's nothing fishy going on there. No, not at all. I mean, there is this possibility that he submitted it because he wanted to make sure all the art categories were represented, you know, the first year that the arts were included.
文学。或者更具体一点，是诗歌。皮特·斯劳森，那首你让我读的置顶诗是他写的吗？就是那首。顾拜旦用化名提交了它，然后赢得了金牌！好吧，我确信这其中没有什么可疑的。不，一点也没有。我的意思是，确实存在这种可能性：他提交这首诗是因为他想确保所有艺术类别都有代表，你知道的，那是艺术被纳入奥运会的头一年。
But obviously, I mean, I can't help but wonder if he was secretly harboring a second motive. I mean, he put a lot into pitching these arts competitions. So, you know, maybe just maybe he knew he really couldn't compete on the sports side, but you know, he wanted to shout out the gold. If there was a podcast Olympics and I could get a gold medal, I would totally be into it. Right? You could found it and then submit your work to it. It'd be the best. Love it. Oh, I really do love it. Well, that's so great. I want to bring this back. I would love to see, you know, what, you know, Michael Phelps could do when it comes to designing a stadium. I mean, that would be so awesome.
但很显然，我的意思是，我禁不住想知道他是否暗藏了第二个动机。我是说，他在推销这些艺术竞赛上花了很多心思。所以，你知道的，也许、只是也许他知道自己在体育方面确实无法竞争，但你知道的，他想要一枚金牌。如果有一个播客奥运会，而且我能拿到金牌，我绝对会参加。对吧？你可以创立它，然后把你的作品提交给它。那将是最棒的。太棒了。噢，我真的很喜欢。好吧，这太棒了。我想把这个恢复。我很想看看，你知道的，迈克尔·菲尔普斯在设计体育场时能做些什么。我的意思是，那太棒了。
Or how well he can sculpt. I mean, I don't know. Like, the possibilities are endless. Well, I love imagining an Olympics like that. Thanks, Kurt. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Claire Mullen, Avery Truffleman, and Kurt Kohlstedt. Music by Swan Real, technical production by Shreve Yousef, remixed by Martin Gonzalez. Thanks to the team at Radio Diaries who provided us with some tape from their documentary,
或者他的雕刻技术有多好。我的意思是，我不知道。就像，可能性是无限的。好吧，我喜欢想象那样的一场奥运会。谢谢你，库尔特。《99% Invisible》本周由克莱尔·马伦、艾弗里·特拉夫曼和库尔特·科尔斯特德制作。音乐由斯旺·里尔创作，技术制作由什里夫·尤塞夫负责，混音由马丁·冈萨雷斯完成。感谢Radio Diaries团队为我们提供了一些来自他们纪录片的磁带，
A Movement, A Massacre, and Mexico's 50-year search for the truth, produced by Anayatse Diaz-Cortez. It tells the story of the student protest of 1968 and uncovers a secret behind the government's bloody crackdown. If you haven't listened to Radio Diaries before, they are probably the best audio documentarians in the business of all time, so do yourself a huge favor and go listen. Cathy Tu is our executive producer, Delaney Hall is our senior editor, Nikita Apte is our intern.
该片由阿纳亚茨·迪亚斯-科尔特斯制作，讲述了“一场运动、一场大屠杀以及墨西哥对真相长达50年的搜寻”。它讲述了1968年学生抗议的故事，并揭露了政府血腥镇压背后的秘密。如果你以前没有听过Radio Diaries，他们可能是史上最优秀的音频纪录片制作人，所以帮自己一个大忙去听听吧。凯茜·图是我们的执行制作人，德兰尼·霍尔是我们的资深编辑，尼基塔·阿普特是我们的实习生。
The rest of the team includes Chris Barube, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Ley, Basha Madan, Joe Rosenberg, Gabriella Gladney, Kelly Prime, Jacob Maldonado Medina, Nina Potuck, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of visible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the Stitcher and SiriusXM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building, in beautiful Uptown, Oakland, California, birthplace of Kamala Harris. You can find us on all the usual social media sites, as well as our Discord server.
团队的其他成员包括克里斯·巴鲁贝、杰森·德莱昂、埃met特·菲茨杰拉德、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、维维安·莱、巴沙·马丹、乔·罗森伯格、加布里埃拉·格拉德尼、凯利·普赖姆、雅各布·马尔多纳多·梅迪纳、尼娜·波图克以及我，罗曼·马尔斯。《99% Invisible》的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作。我们是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客家族的一部分，现在总部设在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市上城潘多拉大厦以北六个街区，这里是卡玛拉·哈里斯的出生地。你可以在所有常见的社交媒体网站以及我们的Discord服务器上找到我们。
There are over 4,500 people there talking about the Power Broker, talking about architecture, talking about all kinds of things, podcasts that they recommend. It's just a great place to be. There's a link to that as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那里有4500多人讨论《权力掮客》、讨论建筑、讨论各种各样的事情以及他们推荐的播客。那真是一个好地方。在99PI.org上有一个指向该频道的链接以及99PI的每一期往期节目。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。